just about every woman in the world
wants to be Marcia Gay Harden right now
you actually got a handful of Rob Lowe
on the red carpet last night but Marcia
I've got one up on you have you been in
the bedroom with Rob is it weird that
I'm holding a pink stuffed pony oh you
you know better than I would isn't this
with all like young girls lit in my
bedroom it's not really a bedroom it's a
promo set of a teen girls room plastered
with photos from Rob's heartthrob days
now he's about to be roasted hard on
Comedy Central
David Spade hey sexy David Spade will be
the roastmaster emcee where anything is
fair game am i stupid to have said yes
to it well Rob it's a mistake
you've got material you know that right
I could still get out of it I probably I
think no no seriously what why did you
say yes because I love those roasts yeah
I love them they make me laugh and and
look maybe there's something wrong with
me but the meaner they are the more I
like it okay and the people who can take
it or my heroes but it hasn't been about
you yes I know it's easy for me to say
when is it that somebody else post
roasts Rob joins code black on CBS that
pretty much takes him out of the running
for another rumor job Kelly Ripa's
co-host it was very flattering talk that
was but buzzing around but you know I'm
I'm still loving acting I I'm still I'm
an actor and they'll be we were just
talking about Lily Ripa and in here she
is not there you're being roasted
unbelievable not me I was just wondering
if you still love acting but I heard you
said you do so that's great now I can
take off Kelly I still love it thank you
yeah so I will just be there and try to
stay in his shadow as a
last twenty years I love that and then
we'll just see what happens but he
should be taking a lot of punches I'll
get some shrapnel okay so back to the
bedroom I mean set there are photos here
that I've never seen before I don't know
what's happening there there's this
which is I'm kind of kind of have it
going on here and by the way what says
edgy and cool more than a Toronto
t-shirt it really does show just how
much you've done like you've done the
damn thing Rob Lowe that part does make
me feel good all kidding aside to look
back at all of it and go and and to
still be in the middle of it yeah you
know absolute that's the most fun of all
look at the sun damage what's happening
is you're saying That's not me
all of those were you robbed